this is how you can get into property as
a beginner with no money many people
think that they need to save up for a
deposit to buy a house and rent it out
if they want to be a property investor
that is the old-fashioned way you might
be watching this right now with 500
pounds in your bank what do you do if I
teach you to save up money which is by
the way what most people will tell you
they'll say work hard save money you
know have an icer account and work
really hard at me really patient for 10
years and then finally you've got a
deposit to buy a house that is what we
call the slow way I'm going to be
showing you the fast ways and the way
that you can do it with start with no
money and I'll tell you something guys
I've done this myself I have done
challenges social experiments where I've
stripped myself from all my identity and
from my cash from my bank and boom
within seven days I'm doing deals making
money in property and this is the video
this is the one you're here this is the
one I'm going to show you exactly how to
do it so if you like my videos do
smash the like button but more
importantly
things like burn is
the action on what I say so the first
way is this partnering with other people
partnering just because you don't have
the money to buy properties that doesn't
matter because to buy properties there's
actually four things that you need you
need the ability to find the deal you
need the skills to negotiate and project
manage the deal you need the team in
place The Power Team the builders the
agents the mortgage brokers and finally
you need the money so let's say that
you've not got any money could you get
the skills to negotiate the deals yes
the skills to be able to oversee the
project yes could you get the skills to
find the deals yes could you get the
people in place to oversee it and the
management and The Power Team
so if you don't have the money go get
the other stuff that you need and then
partner with somebody that's got the
money I'm gonna give you a really really
good basic tip right now okay find a
banging deal invest in yourself first
educate yourself get good get the skills
get the team well I when I was 17 I just
joined business networking International
went and joined BNI paid a thousand
pounds boom I was a teenager why did I
do that now I've got connections in that
group with Builders and plumbers and
mortgage brokers now I've leveled up why
did I go on courses everyone laughed at
me why are you going on property courses
you've got no money because I know that
I'm my best assets before I invest in
property I'm gonna invest it myself then
once you start finding good deals what
you can do is you can approach investors
okay and you can say hey I'd like your
opinion I've got a deal I'm looking at
potentially buying myself or maybe
partnering with an investor on I'd love
if you can have a look at the deal and
give me your opinion on it and if the
deal is a banger there's a good chance
that they'll say that's a good deal so
what are you offering to your partners
what I'm offering to my partners is I'm
going to give them a fixed return on
investment of 10 oh I'm gonna give them
a 50 profit share
and then they might go well I've got a
bit of money I could potentially be
interested
boom and if they don't if they just go
oh that was good good for you then go
and speak to somebody else hey I've got
this deal I'd love your opinion on it
you know would it be right if I could
spend 10 20 minutes showing you the deal
and getting your thoughts don't sell to
them don't pitch them show them how
banging the deal is so that's the first
way and you can also partner with people
by deal selling and deal selling is a
similar thing you know you could go
right now you could you could Book on a
networking event a property networking
event and you could go and meet a whole
bunch of property investors even though
you've got no money and ask them
questions ask them what kind of
properties are you invest in interesting
oh you're looking for development
opportunities in London oh you're
looking for flips in the Northeast if I
can find you a good property investment
that suits your criteria on a deal
sourcer you know would you be open to
paying me a finders fee of 3 000 pounds
these property investors that you're
meeting at these networking events
they've got hundreds of thousands of
pounds if you can negotiate them a good
deal would they pay you three grand yes
so think about partnering packaging and
selling deals second way you can do it
instead of trying to buy houses
the problem we're trying to buy houses
is traditional way of buying houses is
to save up money buy a house takes time
takes years what about if you could
control properties instead so you can do
that via something called a purchase
option agreement a purchase option
agreement is when you see a house that
you like the look of and you say to the
owner you say look I'd like to buy it
but I don't have the money right now
would you be open to renting it from me
for five years and then I'll buy it at
the end of the five years now you might
be thinking but why would anybody do
that well there's a lot of people right
now I'm right now
that have got their houses for sale and
the same house
is for rent
so then you're gonna rent it from them
with the agreement that you're not going
to live in it yourself you're going to
take control of the property you're
going to rent it from them and then
you're going to rent it out at a higher
amount be creative Rent It Room by room
rent it short stay let's
you're getting cash flow and what are
you going to do with that cash flow
you're going to save it up right and
then you're going to use that as the
deposit in five years when you have the
option to buy the house I mean this is
just like basic stuff it blows people's
brain because they've never done it but
it's very standard way of buying
properties amongst wealthy people also
what about controlling properties on a
commercial rent to rent there's so many
hotels in Birmingham you know Wembley
all over the place and I'm looking at
the hotels and I'm thinking they're
charging a hundred pounds a night this
small little hotel room
and I'm walking into the hotel and I'm
saying hey I'm asking the cleaners
because the cleaners know everything I'm
saying to the cleaners what's the you
know how many rooms are full in this
hotel and I said it's all for so the
hotels are fully booked but they're next
door to the hotel is an apartment block
and the apartment block is renting out
for 700 pounds per apartment and I'm
thinking if they're renting out for a
hundred pound a night that's 3 000
pounds a month per room
an apartment which is a not a room it's
a suite you got a lounge a kitchen
that's renting out for 700 pounds a
month that's way less why is that
renting out for so much more than that
because that has got cleaners it's
systemized it's short stay let's what
about if I could systemize the apartment
block what about if I could speak to the
apartment block owner and rent the whole
thing off him this is what I do I just
secured a hotel on a rent to rent a
couple weeks back in Oxfordshire I saw a
massive building it was an apartment
block well I would say massive 34 units
which is you know quite big and I agreed
a five-year lease with the owner which
I've actually extended to 10 I've also
got an option on it I'll probably Vlog
it at some point I'm paying them x
amount it's 100 Grand a year I'll make a
couple hundred thousand pounds on top
but you don't even have to do it in a
power block you could just do it in one
apartment I'll rent it for 700 and then
I'll rent it out as short stay let's as
long as you have the right contract in
place the right agreements in place
check the head lease the mortgage
criteria make sure that there's no
restrictions on average our students
would do this make 900 pounds per
apartment when they do this you do that
two or three times you've replaced an
average salary and how much money do you
have to put that up front next to
nothing so those are some ideas of how
you can get into property starting with
zero money as a beginner if you want to
come and spend a full day with me where
I can go into much more detail on these
strategies then I'd love to meet you in
person I'm going to leave a link in the
description get booked on and the best
thing is it's only a pound one pound
let's spend a day together let's get you
trained up I want to see you smashing
out there this year
[Music]
thank you